hi I'm buck Schwartz more mayor of
Brogden Pennsylvania home of the Brogdon
Lions muhannad rock quarry and hopefully
the future Amazon HQ - word is that New
Jersey's offering seven billion dollars
in tax breaks
well brogdon's willing to sweeten the
pot - we'll take ten billion dollars in
tax burdens and ship them off you on to
our local businesses and residents no
liens I'm Mayor Steve Hightower of
Anderson Virginia home of the Anderson
Tigers and the world's best-tasting ham
Anderson's known for our small-town
charm and our unyielding crony
capitalism he'll our town seals mr.
monopoly beaten up a coal orphan and
we're running to grease the wheels with
15 billion dollars in refundable tax
credits because we do what it takes here
in Anderson go Tigers hi buck Schwartz
more again looks like our friend south
of the mason-dixon line to put on their
big-boy pants ooh well here in Brogdon
we're willing to give you twenty billion
dollars in direct kickbacks we're
willing to go the extra mile for you
here in Brogdon in fact over the weekend
me and the city manager drove down to
Anderson Virginia and focused on the
windows go lions
well jokes on them fixing all these
broken windows it's gonna be great for
our infrastructure spending our economy
is going to the moon that's why we're
prepared to offer you guys thirty
billion dollars in unmarked
non-sequential bills no questions asked
we do what it takes
face it we got the land we got the
people we got the desire the only thing
we don't have is our respect for
taxpayers or a basic understanding of
economics come on down to Anderson
Virginia or should I say Amazon Virginia
that's right we will change the name of
our town go Tigers Amazon ok first
Tigers don't live in the Amazon so
that's just stupid
second we've put 50 billion taxpayer
dollars in an untraceable overseas
account that's yours for the taking
third will not only rename the town will
rebrand the Lions the Amazon Prime's the
jerseys will have prime numbers on the
back of them the box seats law looked
like Amazon Prime boxes I mean the the
whole concept just sangs really go
primes Amazon Prime's
all right bullet train you want a bullet
train cuz I eminent domain this whole
[ __ ] town and build you the fastest
train you ever saw
we'll take it all the way to Seattle I
don't give a [ __ ] you can blow up
anything you want just for fun around
here you think I'm bluffing watch go
Tigers okay let's get real Real Talk I
have a shipment of pure uncut cocaine
flown in from Bogota every weekend like
women men hell I'll jump on the pile I
just just chance I could be senator
governor I will do anything for those
jobs I will do anything I have my hand a
legal document that entitles all
high-ranking employees at Amazon to hunt
and kill for sport human beings inside
the city limits of Amazon Virginia all I
have to do is sign it you have not lived
until you have seen the light go out in
another man's eyes fooling the knowledge
it was your cunning and guile that
extinguished it a candle snuffed out
that will never burn again to take a
soul from another human being is the
bottom of H Energy touch face
mr. Lowrey
new taggers
[Music]
you
[Music]